que la parole est à madame anne
grommerch
le président et cher collègue ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
votre gouvernement a rendu public hier
un bilan d'étape de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
un satisfecit d'autocongratulation qui
ne donne pourtant aucune indication sur
l'impact des nouveaux rythmes sur
l'apprentissage des enfants
autrement dit vous présenter un bilan
qui ne traitent pas de l'essentiel de la
réforme c'est pourtant bien ça le coeur
du sujet si on vous écoute c'est tout va
bien circulez ya rien à voir
mais la question des enfants et
principal et les bienfaits de la réforme
ne soit en aucun cas prouvé vous omettez
également de parler des conséquences
pour les communes et des difficultés
pour les mères alors que beaucoup
d'ajustements sont encore nécessaires la
réforme des rythmes scolaires est loin
de faire l'unanimité
que vous le vouliez ou non elle engendre
des problèmes d'organisation des
problèmes de financement des inquiétudes
cette réforme est symptomatique des
contraintes supplémentaires que vous
confiée aux maires des charges et des
dépenses qui leur sont transférées
quand dans le même temps vous baisser
les dotations sans aucune concertation
oui monsieur le premier ministre les
maires sont d'accord pour faire des
économies
oui monsieur le premier ministre les
maires sont d'accord pour faire des
réformes des efforts sur les dépenses
mais cela doit se faire en concertation
avec les élus locaux
cela doit se faire sans risquer de
mettre en péril certains services
publics locaux
plus que jamais nos concitoyens ont
besoin d'écouté et des de la part des
élus proximité vous devez les
accompagnent et non pas leur forcer la
main
cela doit se faire sans que l'état ne
transfère toujours davantage de charges
non compensés aux communes monsieur le
premier ministre
comptez vous ouvrir le dialogue pour un
rééchelonnement des baisses de dotations
qui aujourd'hui font porter un effort
financier disproportionnée aux communes
et intercommunalités je vous remercie
merci la parole qu'à madame maryse
lebranchu
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée il y avait encore il y avait
deux parties dans votre question la
place des enfants
et la charge entre guillemets que
représenterait ses enfants dans nos
communes je pense que pour vous reste
pour voraces
madame la députée c'est vrai que pour me
déplacer beaucoup sur le territoire on a
trouvé beaucoup d'accords au niveau des
intercommunalités qui permettent
justement dans les petites communes et
c'est un vrai projet de société que nous
défendons qui permettent aux petites
communes rurales d'offrir enfin aux
enfants non seulement et halte-garderie
traditionnel mais un accès à la culture
mais pas le second sur la baisse des
dotations
on ne peut pas dire blanc et noirs en
même temps je lisais pendant le week-end
une publication de l'ancien ministre
james overs qui écrit que dans cette
période actuelle il faut baisser la
dépense publique de 25 milliards par an
nous n'avons réussi qu'à proposer
effectivement vous pourriez nous en
faire reproche que 50 milliards mais
dans la mesure où 20% de cette dépense
publique est porté par les collectivités
territoriales
il n'y avait aucune raison que le sujet
soit exclue et qu'on ne fasse comme si
on ne le voyait pas d'autant d'autant je
le rappelle souvent que ceux qui
assurent la peau sont le revenu ou la
csg l'ensemble des recettes de tva de
l'état sont les mêmes qui payent l'impôt
local
donc nous devons toujours globalisé la
recette en même temps que nous globalise
on l'appelle de la dépense et je vous
rappelle madame la députée que nous
avons avec des associations d'élus faire
effort pour que ce soit juste en
augmentant la dsr la dotation de
solidarité rurale en augmentant la
dotation de solidarité urbaine et en
faisant que les communes plus riches
contribuent cette fois plus que les
communes pauvres c'était notre
engagement
merci madame la part